well let's take a look more closely at
the situation on the ground in ukraine
ed arnold a former british army officer
and research fellow for european
security at the royal united services
institute is here at the screen ed we've
seen some absolutely horrific
bombing uh and attacks in the town what
is the latest in the east
so as you said there's an
intensification of the russian offensive
in the east and it's very much focused
around the town of sevilla donetsk which
is the easternmost portion which is in
ukrainian control elsewhere in the
donbass actually russian air forces are
switching from offensive to defensive
operations especially in the north and
to the east of kharkiv to essentially
protect their reinforcement and
logistics routes and it shows that
russian forces are adapting because they
didn't manage to do that
around kiev in the earlier stages of the
war in terms of the intensification
around sevilla donetsk in the last
couple of days we've seen russian forces
break out west from papasna and start to
try and dominate the high ground to the
west of that city which puts him in a
more advantageous position for an
assault on severe donetsk and also
targeting and destroying one bridge
yesterday to the river to the west which
is a critical ukrainian not only
reinforcement routes but also withdrawal
routes and now they
have several genetics on three sides and
we're expected to see the battle start
from uh today
elsewhere down in the south of the of
the country actually the russian
position is very very strong at the
moment now that they have taken mariopol
they have control all the way from
russia in the east over to the west
and kirsan which is critically a land
bridge
to crimea russia has stated that their
objective is also to move from the west
of kirsan all the way over to
translating history on the moldovan
border and we've heard reports of uh
troops massing in curson uh for around
six to eight weeks now and we still have
not seen the offensive so the choices
now for the russians or to try and
create another land bridge
which is 330 k which is a riskier option
or they might try and consolidate what
they have
there and what that enables them to do
is actually to try and control the whole
of the uh southern coastline of ukraine
well the g7 are very much worried about
at the moment is actually to the south
of odessa and the black sea uh ukraine
is a huge exporter of wheat
22 million tons of grain is currently in
silos pre-harvest and the u.n assesses
that 36
nations within the region and the globe
rely on russian and ukrainian wheater 50
of imports so at the moment there's a
bit of a food security crisis going here
and what needs to happen for that is for
the grain to actually leave via the
ports but for that you need
russian cooperation
at the u.n that's going to be very
difficult because russia could veto any
u.n security council resolution it's
very difficult to put nato forces in the
black sea for the same reasons that it
would
cause a risk of
russian
escalation and at the moment really
focused in on making sure that those sea
lions could potentially open but of
course this is what putin wants he's
trying to weaponise the food supply and
he's making sure that he has a
negotiating position to get further
concessions from ukraine in the future